July's PlayStation plus games have been
confirmed and the PS5 is getting some
exciting new gaming accessories plus a
skull and bones update all this on
today's Gamespot news
after initially leaking as PlayStation
plus games are known to do Crash
Bandicoot 4 it's about time man of Medan
and arcade again have been confirmed to
be your included titles for July on the
service subscribers of any tier will now
be able to enjoy the entire Bandicoot
Saga the original Three games already a
part of the PS plus collection via the
insane Trilogy man of Medan is a horror
game from developer supermassive which
recently put out another spooky title
The Quarry and arcade to get in is an
arena shooter with both PVE and PVP
elements all three titles will be
available to download at no additional
cost for subscribers on July 5th that's
not the only thing of Sony's sleeve the
company also announced that it is
releasing a number of accessories as a
part of a new gaming brand in zone the
initial lineup consists of two monitors
and three gaming headphones with both
sets of products designed for use with
PCS and PlayStation consoles the pair of
monitors are being dubbed the M9 and M3
the M9 Sports a 27 inch 4K display with
a 144hz refresh rate supporting video
input for HDMI 2.1 DisplayPort and USBC
the device can connect to a beefy gaming
rig a MacBook Air or any device in
between and thanks to features like Auto
HDR tone mapping this monitor is built
to make tinkering with settings on a
PlayStation 5 less cumbersome later in
the year the more affordable M3 will
drop sporting a lower resolution 1080p
display but increasing the refresh rate
to 240 hertz considering the PS5 only
supports up to 120 hertz output the
higher refresh rate really only concerns
users looking to connect the monitor to
a PC the endzone headphone line consists
of a wired option the H3 and two
wireless options the H7 and H9 the
differences in the wireless options have
mostly to do with active noise
cancellation the H7 lacking support for
the feature but with an increased
battery life due to that fact for more
details on both the Monitor and
headphone lineups head to gamespot.com
a game that you might be playing this
year with your fancy new Endzone
accessories is Skull and Bones yes
that's Skull and Bones the Pirate game
from Ubisoft that has been in
development hell a supposed Xbox store
listing dated the game for November 8th
2022 as well as what bonus content those
who pre-order the game can expect its
additions to include those with the
knowledge of the game's release have
corroborated the November release date
with kotaku's Ethan gatch providing
further details according to gatch Skull
and Bones was initially slated to go on
sale this summer before then being
pushed to September and then finally the
November date which seems like it might
be a lock thanks to a reported subsidy
agreement between developer Ubisoft
Singapore and its host nation gag also
states that there was reportedly going
to be a closed Network test for the game
in June but it was scrapped due to the
quality of the build which might explain
its internal delay to the last possible
moment that's everything on today's
Gamespot news please like And subscribe
to keep up to date with all the latest
gaming info and make sure to head over
to gamespot.com for all the additional
details on today's stories
[Music]